[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le 28
novembre 2016 voici les titres retour
sur le second tour de la primaire de la
droite et du centre françois fillon est
sorti vainqueur de ce deuxième tour avec
près de 70% des voix l'histoire en fait
à versailles et la 9ème édition du salon
histoire de dire s'est déroulé ce vin ce
samedi 26 et dimanche 27 novembre au
programme rencontre avec les auteurs
conférence nous étions sur place et puis
c'est le plus bel exploit du week end
pour le sport yvelinois en fédérale 3 de
rugby plaisir deuxième du classement
s'est imposé face au leader invaincu ris
orangis sur son terrain mais nous
débutons ce journal avec la primaire de
la droite et du centre qui a livré son
verdict hier soir tout à fait haussmann
après des mois de campagne les électeurs
ont tranché la droite et le centre ont
dorénavant leur candidat officiel en vue
de la présidentielle de mai prochain et
il s'agit de françois fillon près de 3
millions de votants en france se sont
prononcés en faveur de l'ancien premier
ministre de nicolas sarkozy est le
résultat provisoire fait état de 66 5%
des suffrages elle la vérification des
chiffres est encore en cours et c'est
sensiblement le même résultat que l'on
retrouve dans les yvelines cette fois ci
le résultat est définitif 65,4 % pour
françois fillon et on notera que la
participation est en hausse de 3000
personnes ils sont 160 6122 avoir fait à
le hêtre déplacement hier écouter
d'ailleurs ces quelques réactions à la
sortie des bureaux de vote pour les
électeurs cette primaire va permettre à
tous les débats présidentiels de gagner
en clarté je suis venu voter aujourd'hui
à la primaire parce que j'estime que la
france n'est plus la france
k aujourd'hui la france est décliné
après cinq années catastrophiques et je
pense qu'il nous faut un homme avec une
ambition grosse comme ça pour pouvoir
sortir notre pays de la bis dans lequel
il se trouve dans le contexte actuel
entre la gauche et la droite ça permet
d'avoir une idée des futures
présidentielles trouve ça très très bien
parce que moi on a là on a le choix de
saint promis c'est un premier vote avant
le vote des présidentielles donc je
trouve ça très très très très bien
puisque moins on peut choisir pour qui
qui va représenter tel ou tel parti et
je dirais même que moi s'il ya une
primaire bien évidemment à gauche si
voter je trouve ça tout à fait logique
après que ça soit un débat d'idées
lors du lent du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle concernant les
réactions des responsables politiques à
présent du côté des vainqueurs françois
fillon à la sénatrice sophie primas
numéro deux des républicains dans les
yvelines soutien de la première heure
estime que le regroupement va maintenant
se faire naturellement le score sans
appel assure la légitimité du désormais
candidat à la présidentielle selon elle
je pensais que les équerres allait se
resserrer au cours du deuxième tour est
en réalité mais je suis agréablement
surprise parce que je pense que c'est un
vote d'adhésion qui s'est
exprimée en réalité les français de
droite est puissante se sont retrouvés
davantage dans le positionnement de
françois fillon est un positionnement de
droite très rapidement avant la fin de
l'année on va tous se serait le lire moi
je vais avec david douillet lancé un
comité départemental invité tous les
gens qui sont investis dans cette
primaire
autre soutien à françois fillon suzanne
blanc c'est la première adjointe de
montigny le bretonneux l'élu l est
républicain estime que cette victoire
n'aurait jamais pu se produire sans le
combat mené sur le terrain par les
militants il ya eu une armée de
mobiliser derrière françois fillon vous
savez on n'a pas ménagé notre peine loin
s'en faut que ce soit ici à montigny que
ce soit dans toutes les villes les
villages de france il a fait un énorme
travail lui-même sur le terrain énorme
énorme énorme énorme hein il est allé
même dans des villages et c'est très
important c'est extrêmement important
parce qu'il y avait des français que
l'on n'entendait plus qui ont parlé il
s'en est inspiré il s'en est bien
inspiré et puis je vous dis moi je crois
que cette cette fantastique armée qui a
été autour de lui à bosser vraiment y'a
pas d'autres mots on a fait énormément
on a on s'est énervé comme dans toutes
les campagnes on n'avait pas y arriver
on est passé dit si on n'avait pas assez
de savoie là mais ça ça a été ça a été
vraiment révélateur avant d'écouter les
soutient alain juppé un mot concernant
la commune de montigny le bretonneux où
siège d'ailleurs susanne blank commune
plutôt centriste alors juppé qui
totalise 46 8% c'est l'un de ses
meilleurs scores et voici la réaction du
maire michel laugier également président
de saint quentin en yvelines et il a un
message à faire passer alors que débute
une toute autre campagne un écart plus
serré qu'au niveau national sur montigny
mais bon comme on t need unis commune
différente et montigny a toujours eu un
comportement très centriste dans ses
choix revoir ce que j'attends du
prochain président de la république
surtout c'est que il facilite le travail
des élus donc il nous faut plus de
liberté liberté d'entreprendre liberté
de gérer au niveau local et surtout que
sonné aussi les moyens qui vont avec
afin que les les habitants puissent être
satisfaits de la gestion de leur ville
alain juppé battue et pourtant les
soutiens dans le département des
yvelines était un nombreux exemples avec
karl olive c'est le maire de poissy
lavette a gagné également animer les
différents elle débat parisien les
différents meetings le combat qui nous
attend aujourd'hui et pendant six mois
c'est bien le défi de remporter
l'élection présidentielle
j'en veux pour preuve le déplacement sur
chacune des manches de cette primaire de
plus de 4 millions de français c'est
légitimer le vainqueur françois fillon a
désormais tout le pouvoir entre
guillemets de pouvoir bien se préparer
avec toutes les sensibilités
mais il est légitimée par ces français
qui souhaitent l'alternance si du côté
de la droite on sonne globalement
l'heure du rassemblement la situation
est un peu plus complexe avec les
centristes de l'udf et surtout du modem
françois bayrou s'était engagé vous le
savez au côté d'alain juppé depuis plus
d'une semaine il très sévèrement le
programme le projet de françois fillon
voici ce qu'en pense bruno myle yens
c'est le président du modem dans le
département des yvelines également
conseiller régional ile de france on va
prendre le temps il faut qu'on
réfléchisse ça va pas faire on va pas
faire faire du jour au lendemain d'abord
c'est pas c'est pas grave on est dans
nos gènes dans nos habitudes on prend
toujours le temps de la réflexion pour
se décider et je peux pas parler à la
place de françois bayrou nous on va
surtout travailler et essayer de
proposer une autre alternative et on
verra on verra on verra l'accueil qui
aurait vu que nous réserve cette
nouvelle alternative qu'on va proposer
la gauche et l'extrême droite
connaissent donc maintenant le nom de
leur adversaire et si le fn se réjouit
de cette victoire en appelant à une
confrontation de projets le ps donc déjà
de mettre en marche le rassemblement
écouter tout d'abord françois simeoni
c'est le responsable fn dans les
yvelines est également et sandrine grand
gang c'est la responsable du ps toujours
dans le département c'est bon le
candidat ultra d'idées run qui porte ce
projet de le cas ce n'est pas la même
d'un justice sociale parce que regarder
par exemple l'augmentation de la tva de
points qui prévoit qui ça va toucher ça
va bien plus riches et des plus humbles
à côté de ça il supprime lisf donc
véritablement nous on porte un projet
patriote un radicalement en opposition
avec ce candidat du système les
élections sont encore suffisamment
longtemps pour qu'il puisse avoir des
changements et c'est pas du tout fait
moi je
n'imagine pas du tout comme certains le
fait que une personne comme fillon soit
au deuxième tour dans les périodes de
tournon qui a des règles il ya des des
valeurs qui sont les nôtres qui doivent
être notre boussole et je pense que
c'est la seule manière de de trouver le
meilleur d'entre nous le meilleur
candidat pour affronter une droite qui
est de plus en plus réactionnaire sur le
plan sociétal et qui est comme très très
libéral sur le plan économique donc
voilà on a des primaires on avait d un
débat qui un cadre qui va s'organiser il
faut juste respecter nos règles et à mon
avis c'est la meilleure façon qu'il n'y
ait aucune contestation et que la
dynamique de rassemblement et soit la
dernière
considère que
que ça soit la jupe et où françois
fillon ou nicolas sarkozy on aurait eu
de toute façon un programme très à
droite mais là il est particulièrement
en
opposition frontale avec tout ce que
l'on porte à gauche et au parti
socialiste voilà pour ces différentes
réactions et puis sachez que les
différents soutiens aux différents
candidats à la primaire de la droite et
du centre de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines ont décidé de se rassembler le
13 décembre à fontenay le fleury une
réunion publique un rassemblement pour
l'alternance organisé par le maire
candidat aux élections législatives
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
merci à vous il fait de ricci ricci
dimanche dernier zumba jets ont été
programmés à bois d'arcy un événement
organisé au profit de personnes en
situation de handicap ils ont pu
s'essayer à la zumba les images de
nicolas dendre
personnes valides ou à mobilité réduite
ils étaient tous réunis pour une zone
pas géant à bois d'arcy un moyen de
s'amuser pour la bonne cause les fonds
récoltés serviront à financer
l'équipement de deux personnes
handicapées là aujourd'hui on est là
pour deux personnes quai paul un petit
garçon de huit ans pour lui acheter un
vélo électrique continue à faire du vélo
avec ses frères et soeurs et puis un
garçon qui s'appelle teddy qui a 27 ans
ses parents ont besoin d'un véhicule
pour aller le chercher
au centre et comme c'est des personnes
âgées ils ont du mal à financer leurs
véhicules une dizaine de professeurs ont
encadré les différentes sessions en
fauteuil roulant ou atteints de maladies
physiques rien n'a empêché les élèves de
se dépenser c'est ce qu'a voulu montrer
l'association un geste en plus avec
cette première édition ben c'est pas
parce qu'on est en fauteuil roulant
qu'on peut pas faire comme les autres en
fait on a tendance à trop nos systèmes
nous mettre à part alors que on a des
enfants qui ont envie de faire
exactement les mêmes choses que les
autres dansent et chantent et faire du
sport s'amuser et e on veut plus voir le
handicap comme quelque chose de triste
de voir quelque chose de joyeux et
s'amuser comme les autres ouais c'était
bien les gestes surtout avec les braves
aziz à la tête les épaules pas les
jambes du slip dans la halle haut du
corps c'était génial je vais en refaire
une autre voie
cette année l'événement a accueilli plus
d'une centaine de participants
l'association espère pouvoir verser 1500
euros à paul et et vit une nouvelle
édition devrait avoir lieu de l'an
prochain
l'histoire en fait à versailles la 9ème
édition du salon histoire de lire s'est
déroulée le week end dernier
au programme rencontre avec les auteurs
conférences ou encore espace livres
jeunesse notre journaliste nicolas
landry était sur place
vers cei au nord l'histoire 180
historiens écrivains ou participer à la
9e édition du salon histoire de lire le
week end du 26 et 27 novembre entre
10000 et 15000 personnes sont venues à
la rencontre des auteurs une
satisfaction pour les organisateurs le
sort de lire c'est vraiment de
transmettre la passion de l'histoire
bien sûr on vend du riz bien sûr il ya
un côté librairie d'histoire mais c'est
d'abord une transmission delà de la
passion pour l'histoire yvelinois de
cette édition erik orsenna est venu
présenter son dernier ouvrage l'origine
de nos amours le romancier versailles y
raconte ses confidences avec son père
concernant les relations avec les femmes
la ville royale en toile de fond tous
les dimanches pendant 30 ans
nous nous rendions rendez nous donnons
rendez vous au restaurant la flottille
qui est au bord du grand canal j'aime
faire ça il se doit beaucoup à
versailles son arrivée dans la région
versaillaise quand j'avais 15 ans je
l'équité sans jamais la quitter quand
j'en avais 42 je me devais de venir à
versailles ne serait ce que pour dire
merci l'histoire c'est aussi les
présidents de la république ancien
conseiller diplomatique du président
socialiste hubert védrine à rééditer lé
monde de françois mitterrand il explique
la gestion des controverses géopolitique
par la france dans les années 80-90
professeur d'histoire politique jean
garrigues à lui détaillé l'incarnation
de la fonction présidentielle
dans un ouvrage illustré intitulé
président au coeur du pouvoir et c'est
très intéressant d'avoir les réactions
ça peut être des lacs rossi des rien ne
remplace le contact direct des cons
parce que souvent les gens qui viennent
ils ont déjà lu d'autres livres dont ils
ont des idées où ils ont vu une émission
donc c'est un d'éléments qui est amendé
biens indispensables à la maturation de
la réflexion pour les livres suivants
d'échangés toujours extrêmement
fructueux je comprends mieux ce qui peut
intéresser mes lecteurs j'essaie de leur
expliquer aussi de quoi par le parlement
livres et et j'en sors toujours très
enrichi donc c'est vraiment un plaisir
l'an prochain le salon histoire de lire
fêtera son dixième anniversaire de
nombreuses surprises sont d'ores et déjà
prévues
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines continue sa
campagne de séduction auprès du public
francilien ce week end l'opération
hashtag tous en piste s'adresser aux
étudiants internationaux
une quinzaine d'entre eux ont répondu à
l'appel
l'objectif prioritaire est de rendre
accessible et de démocratiser la
pratique du cyclisme sur piste plus
grand nombre donc aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on fait en partenariat avec la vélo
école de paris sud la cité universitaire
internationale de paris voilà l'idée
c'est vraiment d'étendre le pouvoir
d'attraction du vélodrome dont paris au
niveau du grand paris l'amb surprise
parce que j'aurais jamais pensé de faire
et ça m'a énormément plu en fait c'était
génial il avait fait la promotion de
cette journée au forum de l'étudiant
début octobre et j'ai trouvé ça super
intéressant d'avoir l'opportunité de
refaire du vélo en salle c'est la fin de
ce set 8 journal merci voir suivi bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]